ومعنا الان هنا في الاستوديو اللواء فايز
الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا
وسهلا بك هنا معنا في الاستديو اذا
الاقوال تختلف عن الافعال
ما المقصود تحديدا لماذا هذا التشكيك من
الجانب الاوكراني برايك من سحاب
يعني الان هذا القرار هو غير مفاجئ لكثير
من المتابعين وخلال الاسابيع الماضيه كان
الحديث يدور حول انسحاب متوقع ولكن توقيت
الانسحاب هو المفاجاه والطريقه التي سينفذ
بها غير معروفه حتى هذه اللحظه ان ياتي
قرار الانسحاب بهذه الصوره الحديث ك- او
كافه المحللين كان يتوقعوا ان هناك معركه
حاسمه ان هناك معركه حتى تبلغ درجه ما
يطلق عليها كسر العظم لماذا لانهاك القوات
المهاجمه وعدم منح الفرصه
للاحتفاظ بالزمام المبادئه ومحاوله تحقيق
انجازات لاحقا لكن جاء هذا القرار واهله
مكه ادرى بشعابها كان هناك توضيحات لهذا
الاسبوع الان لماذا هذا التشكيك في
الانسحاب سا اولا عندما تصدر اوامر
الانسحاب هذا توجيه عام على المستوى
الاستراتيجي العسكرييه هذا جاء من وزير
الدفاع بناء على ايجاز قدم من قبل القائد
المعني ولكن هذا القائد هو قائد منطقه
العمليه والمنطقه الكليه لمنطقه القتال
ولكن هذا القاطع تحديدا هناك قاضي دون هذا
القائد الذي اصدر هذا الامر وبالتالي
الخطه التي يتم تبنيها من اجل الانسحاب
توضع من قبل القاده الاخرين ضمن التوجيه
وبالان امامهم ثلاثه خيارات اما ان يكون
انسحاب مدبر وهذا يتخذ ويحتاج وقت ويحتاج
اجراءات او ان يكون قتال اعاقه او ان يكون
انسحاب فوضوي اقرب الى الهزيمه لهذا السبب
حتى هذه اللحظه ما هي ميكانيكيات الانسحاب
لم تحدد بعد اذا كان انسحابا مدبرا قد
يكون القائد في بعض الحالات يريد ان يوقع
خسائر يريد ان يحتفظ بقواتهم متزنه قد
تاخذ ايام او اسابيع واذا كان انسحابا
فوضيا قد ياخذ ساعات او ايام معدوده اذا
الصوره غير الميدانيه غير واضحه للجانب
الاخراني اذا ثلاث سيناريوهات ولكن ما سبق
الانسحاب هو طلب لاجلاء السكان ثم
الانسحاب
هل لهذه التفصيل اهميه هنا وهله دلاله
مثلا في ان ترجح احد هذه السيناريوهات
لا هو لا تستطيع ان اقول لانه حتى وجهه
النظر مختلفه ما بين الجانب الروسي
والجانب الاوكراني الجانب الاوكراني كان
يتحدث عن تهجير قصري وانزامي واجبارهم على
الخروج واعطاهم كما يقال الدب من حيث
التوقيت الجانب الروس كان يتحدث بطريقه
مغايره ان هو من اجل تخفيف الخسائر الى
غير ذلك اما الان تم اجلاء حوالي 80,000
وبالتالي تعتبر المنطقه
الا من ابى او اختفى الان انا اتحدث عن
ميكانيكيات معركه ميكانيكيه المعركه
المنطقه العسكريه يقول انه لابد من ان
يكون انسحابا مدبر له ميكانيكياته له
اجراءاته ياخذ وقتا يوقع خسائر تنسحب
القوات وهي بحاله اتزان لتنتقل من موقع
قتالي الى موقع اخر واستدارات الى تصريحات
القائد الروسي قال ان من المهام
المستقبليه هو بناء خطه دفاعيه واستخدامها
في عمليات هجوم محدود وام امكانيه توظيفها
في مناطق اخرى هذا هذا الكلام اذا انا
كمحلل اعتمدته اقول يجب ان يكون الانسحاب
مدبر حتى تبقى القوات متزنه وقادره على
تنفيذ المهام المستقبليه بينما في حاله
انسحاب السريع قد يتحول الى هزيمه ويت هذا
القوه تفقد اتزانها ولا يمكن توظيفها
مستقبلاني
نعم العموم حتى تتضح الامور بشكل اكمل
طبعا هذا ما لدينا الان سنتابع اي هذه
السيناريوهات ربما هو الارجح على العموم
نشكرك جزيلا
شكرا جزيلا